reject nation what is going on greg here
today so right now it is about four
o'clock in the morning i cannot sleep
because i am way too anxious about
fighting for my dead center seats for
imax for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness so i just gotta
wait till they go on sale but my buddy
paul from heavy spoilers go check out
his moon night episode 2 breakdown by
the way he's telling me that there's a
special trailer that's supposed to go on
youtube and i'm going to wait to upload
this one when that's officially up on
youtube but it's it's already a pre-roll
and that pre-roll's already on twitter
so i'm just going to watch it right now
since i got nothing else to do so thank
you paul for giving me a heads up if you
guys haven't seen our moonette episode 2
reaction you can check that out by the
way too after this video but yeah if you
could leave a like i would very much
appreciate that subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our review for doctor strange two is up
on the channel all right enough chit
chat let's see what's in this special
look
[Music]
all right it's 30 seconds long it's
probably gonna watch it twice i've been
dreaming
the same dream
oh every morning
the same
tommy
night where
nightmare okay of the multiverse
depends on us
[Applause]
oh [ __ ]
you got the third eye
doctor screen to the multiverse of
madness tickets on sale now
they're on sale now for me i mean they
probably are by the time this video is
live let's watch that again oh yes you
taught me a bill i chose the right shirt
for this video i've been dreaming
the same dream
amy nightmare is the villain of the
multiverse
of sexy about sinister strange with that
third eye i don't know what's doing it
for me but
it's doing it it's happening all right
guys well i feel like there is some good
stuff in here to talk about for sure i
want to know what your guys's theories
are down below and what the hell you
think is going on show your know-it-all
comments down below as we were kicking
this off the the first that stands out
to me actually is what's being said at
the very top when dr strange is saying
i've been dreaming and then it overlaps
into what wanda is saying i've been
dreaming the same dream and every
morning the same nightmare it's
interesting how you put it into the
certain context because it looks like in
other trailers at least that dr strange
himself is probably experiencing things
that feel like dreams maybe premonitions
or maybe he's living out the memories or
experiences of some of his variants or a
particular variant and that's what feels
like a nightmare but it feels so real
and here when it's overlapping into
wanda when she's been saying i've been
dreaming the same dream it seems like
her dream is her being able to be wanda
and have her children have her family
tommy and billy and then she wakes up
and that dream is not a reality so her
her living circumstances are the
nightmare the fact that she doesn't have
that dream attained is what equals the
nightmare however we did see in the
other trailer the official second
trailer she does interact with whomever
that wanda variant is the wanda that was
able to have a family from what i'm able
to gather at least from the way they're
slicing the trailer together you know
marvel they're really good at misleading
us but maybe they're really clueing us
in this time i imagine the ways how some
of this plot might actually progress is
that at first the scarlet witch that
we're following are wanda maximoff she's
experiencing this dream but really she's
experienced it through the lens of one
of her variants so she wants to be able
to sort of attain that you know i've
heard many theories of her traversing
the multiverse and maybe she wants to
take over this wanda's life so she can
have the kids and have the family
somehow they'll be like slammed together
the two of them for a bunch of theories
who knows what's actually going to be
true regardless what i think this
trailer is really clueing us in on is
the fact that there is a wanda variant
out there who has the family she's able
to like
i don't know if it's like astral
projection or she's taking over the body
and in whatever these dreams are that
variant is very much real she's probably
going to be seeking out this dream to
turn it into a reality of sorts what i
really loved about this trailer though
is they really amped up the scarlet
witch as the main villain one of her
lines there you hear her russian accent
bleeding through right where and it's
funny because when you look at one
division they did kind of poke fun at it
you did have you know pietro ralph boner
at one point did say like what happened
to your accent you know they do poke fun
at the fact that her voice went from
like russian to american in the show it
seemed intentional to the point where
it's when she's like you know being a
badass when she's being threatening
that's when the russian girl comes
through that's when the sokopia girl
really comes through so she seemed quite
menacing in this trailer and i was
eating it up i really loved it a lot and
i also want to put this out for those
who watched our reaction to the tv spot
the other day uh that footage of what a
lot of people ourselves included were
thinking like it could be catholic i was
watching you rockstar's video yesterday
and they were pointing out how there was
this other demon on the bottom right and
ifos was theorizing it could be
i wanna say and gyra
i don't know how to pronounce it all
right they're basically elder spawn
demons that are created by catholics so
at least you would get some sort of
connection to k'thon there but i do
believe what everyone has to arrive at
this that sequence there there within
the darkhold temple itself the darkhold
of course as established in the one
division series which will be a major
factor into the whole adventure going on
here and then of course what a lot of
people call sinister strange i don't
know if that's the technical term for
him but sinister strange having a third
eye i mean he probably has more types of
psychic powers but i'm gonna ask for you
like super avid doctor strange comic
book readers because full disclosure i
mean i have the marvel unlimited app and
i catch up on so many comics over there
but i've only recently been diving into
doctor strange comics in preparation for
multiverse and madness so when it comes
to properly theorizing what the third
eye could actually entail you know the
third eye is not something you know
invented by the doctor strange comics or
some philosophical beliefs that the
third eye can see time that there could
be other spiritual dimensional links
that basically allow you to really see
truth and it makes me wonder if like at
some point our doctor strange is going
to awaken his third eye as well either
way that makes him a lot more
intimidating in that specific scene and
i'm curious to see ultimately what will
become of that you guys tell me you tell
me i'm not super confident in theorizing
on that specific point but you guys tell
me but anyway people what did you think
about this tease i thought it was
awesome leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button check out our moon night episode
2 reaction and last but not least i want
to do a p
tyler hague i'm shouting you out right
now because if i were to theorize
who might be awake just
doing fun stuff at this hour
it'd be you so right now tyler if you're
catching this shout out i want you to
message me and i will message you back
right away tyler you've been part of our
patreon page for so long i can't imagine
it without you i would feel like a part
of my heart has left i'd want to astral
project myself into a variant where i
could then be with you permanently you
are the teddy bear of our patreon page
one of the sweetest people i've ever
known seriously and uh just want to be
here personally to tell you thank you
screw it i'm just going to message you
myself tyler i'm shouting you out
in a
in a youtube video right now
i love you buddy
you rock